I'm a human a huge advocate for kids if
I can influence them in any kind of way
I'm trying to how do we get these kids
of the mental psychosis that is pushed
to them
by building their actual self-esteem
social media is just replacing watching
TV playing video games or being outside
at the playground if we stop demonizing
social media and we start putting
pressure on the proper conversation
which is are we actually building kids
self-esteem or are we not
[Music]
thank you
I want to say thank you I have six kids
change the way that I parent gratitude
empathy and I'm not pushing to go to
college anymore let them do what they
want man go taste as long as they put in
work right we wear these they say we're
cups will grind be kind or you love it
that's it man it's awesome thank you so
nice to meet you if you're in my
position and you're looking to build the
number one men's self-development
podcast and brand what would your
strategy be what do you want to happen
are you selling anything to that
audience are you just trying to build
brand awareness build brand for sure
then I would say it's a heavy game of
content filming things post-producing
them the thing that I think most people
continue to not do well is you need to
be on every platform Tick Tock and you
and Facebook and Instagram and Linkedin
really really Grind On guest set output
that's how you win that game too many
people like I want to build the biggest
men's
and then they're putting out three
pieces of content a day instead of 12.
the more you put out the more good
things will happen and you need to
figure out a system film as much as
possible this should be three Clips two
clips nine clips and I think that's how
you do it but you have to remember it
takes time yeah yeah I'm in an
accelerated digital marketing and
analytics program through technical
college amazing program you're more
likely to get a job by dming people on
LinkedIn than you are on getting that
publication while you're doing that
certification which is also good not bad
you should in parallel put out content
on LinkedIn and literally DM and message
Utah based digital firms and being like
on this this is what I'm about literally
getting 113 no's for one person to say
yes I'd have that job
the number one thing we all need to
figure out is how not to give the world
leverage we need to have the leverage in
a way we have leverages through
vulnerability self-awareness good intent
being in a kind place you know I think
life is a race but it's really not or it
is but you're not going to win a 90-year
race by trying to Sprint yeah we got a
podcast going yes maybe like a tip on
how to
grow the podcast consistency matters and
you've got to put in that work that is
the way to build an audience do you guys
enjoy doing it it's fun then you're
[__] then you're good if you're at
every two three weeks there's probably
some subconscious discouragement of it
not growing and I think the way to get
it to grow is actually through the clips
100 the other way to get it to grow is
spend time watching social media and see
which people are on the come up that are
small if you DM them and say yo you want
to be on our podcast they're probably
going to say yes if they only have 5
000. now all of a sudden God willing in
three years you have a Charlie demilio
or Polo G or garyvee on your show three
years before they became who they are
that might be the springboard for you
clip and find Talent that's emerging
those are the two things I'm an
independent musician I've been you know
just tasting the drink for a long time
I'm in a very nice Market we do what's
called like nerd rap nerd rap yeah so
I'm a former teacher so we make rap
songs about education I like it um this
recently become a foster parent okay I'm
getting into children's music I love
that for you thank you as a Creator any
tips on like when you're ready to make a
pivot and you're not sure how your
current audience is going to necessarily
they'll come take it don't just yeah I
mean I went from wine to business it was
a hard pivot and some people were like
yo Wine Guy stop talking about business
I'm here for wine I was like look I'll
give you both you can't worry about your
current audience you just can't it's not
what's in your heart right now I needed
to hear that it's all right so let's let
you know you know it's already there
it's on your heart so what do you do
like you're gonna get less confused who
cares it's not in your heart
yep that's what kind of got me down a
little bit well that's because you are
valuing other people's opinions
yeah
with helping people not value other
people's opinion onion because it is the
quickest path to be in a very good place
you have to be kind to yourself you're
going to have to work on this every day
everybody here has had struggles and
done dumb [__] and needed reset you're
still young don't beat yourself up be
proud of yourself that you have the
strength to know that you need to reach
out to somebody or that somebody reached
out to you and now you're resetting we
all suck at things and we're all good at
things you're welcome it's called ala
ala all love always I love that it's I
want it to be a mindset movement
personally yeah I don't know how much
people will gravitate towards that so
for now it's more it's just my mindset
if one person gravitates for it to win
the reason this all happened to me is I
never needed it to happen
it was just logical to me like if one
person likes my wine videos and learns
about wine then that's good when I
started doing business I'm like if one
person's business gets better that'd be
good when I started talking a little bit
more perspective I'm like that was the
biggest one if one person's perspective
is in a better place because of
something I make then life is good and
so I think if one [__] person changes
their life because of it you won 100
trying to keep that in mind and attack
the yeah well that's because what's good
about keeping that in mind is it
actually makes you patient yeah
I'll have to make some compromises right
and of course it's not mentally allowing
me to agree that I'm making these
compromises professionally in my 30s I
feel like that's fundamentally wrong I I
think that that's what you have to have
I would actually argue some of my least
productive years of my career were in my
30s ironically 30 was what I triggered
in if I said right now as an athlete
what were your worst seasons I would say
28 29 for the only time my career I had
micro I'm even scared to say it out loud
micro complacency but Wine Library did
it so from 22 to 28 I didn't breathe but
at 28 it happened like it was it it was
undeniable that Wine Library was one of
the most successful independent wine
retailers in the country and I kind of
got into a group I built a good team I
didn't want to build a second store you
know I just had micro complacency and
then at 30 I started blind Lottery TV
three months after 30 and that changed
the next 17 years of my career I would
say I had that complacency and nothing
happened
and and I would argue that in 12 years
I'll be doing this and I'll explain how
I had complacency the year after covid
who the heck knows you can't see the
complacency in the time
it was an app it was a in hindsight and
the reality is is there's no reason to
beat yourself up there's no reason to
hold yourself to a standard that doesn't
come natural there's no reason to create
an ideology of you being a superhero
when you're just a human being and I
think your framework is right you could
build the biggest augmented reality
company in the world if your parents
pass away and during that era and you
say wait a minute why didn't I go to
dinner with them once every two weeks or
nothing matters so you've got it you've
got it so if you were able to go back to
10 year olds yeah what are you telling
him one piece of advice with his
entrepreneurial and this is gonna be a
tough one because I was so extreme in
this direction so this may not help you
but it might in the direct but it might
help you in a macro it's okay to take a
Saturday off I was 110 work okay and I
do believe that balance is best and in
hindsight a little few vacation days a
few Saturdays a few ball games just like
doing [__] besides working 20 again
being 20. yeah some 20 year olds it's
like hey you need to start building your
discipline and work ethic other 20 year
olds it's like hey don't put too much
pressure on yourself yeah number one
number one
it's all great to like take advantage of
your youth a lot of kids that are overly
soft and overly like not starting to do
things that are inconvenient wake up at
30 and are struggling too so like the
best thing I can tell a 20 year old
who's a little too chill if you actually
believe even for you you are find
something to be disciplined about that
might be the gym
school just one thing
being tolerant of inconvenience too many
people just want everything to be easy
and the ultimate Comfort is not finding
ways to be comfortable the ultimate
Comfort is to [__] know that you are
comfortable in any adversity
that big adventure challenge in terms of
how to document it the challenge itself
they want to travel from the highest to
the lowest elevation points of each
state using only human power the problem
I'm running into is figuring out whether
I should be branding this for the
challenge or I'm trying to launch a
company around this of helping people to
face that discomfort because so many of
us are afraid to start I think you can
do both or or intertwine it into the
long form that's not a challenge
beeprint was a IP that was a Pokemon
Sesame Street thing that was based on me
making wine and business videos which
brought awareness to it and for many
people here they could give a [__] about
nfts and be friends but for some of them
they do and you could do the same thing
make that content awesome and then for
the business that you're going to build
a percentage of those people are going
to come with that journey and a
percentage is not and that's beautiful
yo how's that cotton candy yo how's the
cotton candy
[Music]
it's good it's good so I didn't even be
here today so I was thinking in line
what I wanted to say to you and I love
all the business stuff I'm not sure we
have bakeries and pizzerias and cooking
stores and stuff but the most important
stuff that you talk about is your
upbringing with your mom because I have
these five kids send them through the
best schools and all stuff that I'm
realizing over time and they all need
something different yes sir even though
one might be a doctor that's right I was
probably going to come and work with me
in the bakery I get it we changed them
back from school and he's coming in he's
working the counter he's eight years old
you know thank you that's the most
important stuff that you post your
upbringing raising children based on
them not based on an ideology
you is everything and more and more of
that gets into the world this place is
going to be real good real fast we're
already turning a lot of Corners come to
hear that I.E help people in the
Hispanic Community yes I'm a business
consultant actually haven't realized
their dream of owning his own rest their
own restaurants their own food
businesses it's amazing food trucks it's
amazing and uh I'm trying to find out
ways to get more into my communities you
know affected more do more of it have
more people to be able to help more
people and so what do you need to help
more people I read my social media and
stuff like that yeah Direct Mail believe
it or not it's an old school but
sometimes that Facebook
is huge next door do you know what next
door is you've got to do that work so
right now I'm very very focused on one I
haven't talked a lot about called the
optimistic otter okay I think optimism
I'm starting to realize like if you
don't have optimism it's kind of over
yeah like if you don't have the if like
you don't think it can be good then it
definitely can't be good I'm
I'm foreign
you're not sure if you like like it I
feel like
the reason I say like is
Clarity comes from the Y
like when you say I don't have the
clarity go all the way it's either in
security to go all the way or lack of
clarity on the why you're even doing it
or what makes you happy it's one of
those two which one does it feel like or
not or might be something else why
that's good that's not a bad thing you
said you were 23. yeah
sometimes when you know you're capable
and you're hungry and ambitious there's
a level of pressure because you're like
I was fortunate that I can do [__] this
is why I push patience so much
because you're putting undue pressure on
yourself for no reason if you realize
that at 39 if you accomplish whatever
your goals and dreams are that that's
just as good as accomplishing it at 25
it's probably better and more likely and
more sustainable then you can start
reframing the way you look at ships
you're welcome Dylan what's good brother
I'm here with bro he came through for
you in the clutch thank you so much for
watching my [__] bro I can't wait to
actually meet you in person as well I
would give the best 2023 keep going love
yourself first everything else will be
figured out
so I own a Direct Mail company tell me
about what's your perspective on print
in the next 10 years so you heard me
earlier right I literally just gave a
guy advice to do Direct Mail which is
funny because I'm a digital guy there
are certain scenarios where I think it
works the world will continue to get
more digital yeah it just is what it is
that doesn't mean that you can't have a
Bible business in print I think there'll
be more price pressure I know that
Facebook ads can do a lot of things that
Direct Mail used to do for me at a more
exciting price and that will continue to
be pressure on your business but there's
going to be paper you will retire and
Prince will still be around yeah
we're in the personal growth like
development I love your content I love
what you put out and I want to do
something similar I've just been scared
of what Judgment of what let's play it
out I'm not good you're not good yeah
here's why it worked for me whether
people said I was good at it or not
I wasn't doing it for that I was doing
it because I thought one or two people
could benefit from it so if you know
that you're doing it from a good place
and you want someone to have a better
life well isn't that more important than
somebody saying you're not good on
camera yes
oh that's it yeah so I've been in the
hospitality industry for quite a while
so I just started a digital marketing
agency for restaurants right now I feel
like with restaurants they are still
very old school very delay when it comes
to Market most restaurants don't feel
brand they do sales exactly and the ones
that feel free and ironically are the
world you come from which was a little
bit more NightLight restaurant not
restaurant I feel like there's still a
lot of Education that comes from that
side of marketing so what would be your
advice to restaurants I've actually
recorded this you you have to become the
content producer of the advice to lead
awareness to your business you're
telling them to make content well you
better [__] make contact I see it
exactly so I think that's the answer you
need to cry
Tick Tock Instagram YouTube shorts you
just got to put in the [__] work let
me give you a really good piece of
advice because I I know this face swap
do not focus on the people that say no
just say what's up to everyone it's like
Hospitality don't try to convince some
[__] restaurant they need it if
they're not there just go to the next
[__] restaurant got it got it
rapper I've been
rap audio interviews and all the Dipsy
hustle I want to expand that right so
help if you would buy shoes how will you
take it would be local
local and destroying the competition you
know putting out music just putting that
yes when you're in the business of Music
you're one song away from having what
you want to happen happen right how much
music you're putting out I'll put it in
like uh right now I have like
who makes things out
like 20 songs how about a song a day a
song a day
and if you can't do a song a day what
about a song a week and if you can't do
a song a week what about a song every
two weeks every two weeks it's gonna be
a song it's your own talent and and how
many at bats you have
if you're in the music business you got
to get music out okay you got to get
that [__] on Soundcloud you gotta get
that [__] on Spotify upload the songs on
Tick Tock that's your business can I get
like uh what are the names with myself
hey what's up everybody it's your boy
right at the whole thing I hear what the
one the only garyvee word of the day is
patience if you want it too fast you
won't get it it's all a beat maker I'm a
producer man not only do I produce me
for an artist but I also like put out my
own stuff like I love it yes Mark and I
struggle is as well obviously I don't
even always got to put like content out
yeah I think my release like a b tape
every week yep and then obviously like
uh content are you dming a bunch of
emerging artists
I put out a mixed Pizza
I would literally go to Instagram and
Tick Tock and I would probably CM 950
people people had 5 000 to 200 000
followers on Instagram and Tick Tock and
I would hit those people up because
they're still on the come up right I
would have hit up Drake
too much competition but I would hit up
the next Drake who's at 8 000 followers
on Instagram pound those people right
quick question so I'm an attorney
divorce attorney 10 years busy as I
could be question now is like that type
of business where I have personal
connects with my clients how do I scale
something like that or I know you've got
like
vaynermedia is the same thing I was
garyvee and I built a massive marketing
company by letting them know when you
buy us when you have us it's not just me
you need to build up your people and so
when you meet with a person that's going
through a divorce and you sit down with
them and you're you meet with them
you're like it's me there's Johnny
here's Karen it's a team
and then you build people up you're like
Dustin's better at videography than I am
Sally might be better at a certain part
of litigation Ryan might be better at
right everyone's like I can't scale him
like you're not building people up yeah
yeah yeah so I've been on a remote job
for the last three years I got laid off
this last week I'm a photographer and
I'm building a business my photos are in
Lululemon and every store in Utah right
now wow I'm trying to kill it but I need
some stability she's three months
pregnant congratulations and we I need
to like keep growing my business right
so you need to get a job because you
need that peace of mind of something
stable right what I do in that situation
is I apply to literally 8 000 jobs and
try to get as many interviews as
possible if you're able to get three or
four interviews you analyze them based
on how much it pays you but how much
free time it gives you okay I get a lot
of people especially now it's starting
to happen hey I'm looking for a job and
I'm like how many jobs did you apply to
and people are like two and I'm like you
only play two jobs today and like this
week and I'm like what are you doing
yeah you have the internet this is not
1985 where you have to drive somewhere
and see Help Wanted sign so just go ham
on apply it
but find the ratio that lets you do what
you want if I'm trying to one-up my my
fees to make a little bit more with my
photography you just ask just keep
asking keep building number one thing
for people that do haircuts lawn work
photography if you are a service
provider it is me the number one rule is
every job that comes up next is more
expensive until the market tells you no
and you're gonna get some no's yeah but
if you can feel if you're getting enough
asks well then you can keep going if
you're not getting asked and you start
going down okay
and did you know that it would be going
into it my most fulfilling project is
what we're doing right this second the
building of a personal brand that was
going to provide value to
didn't even cross my mind if that's what
I was doing at first it's beyond
fulfilling look at this you know it's
like but they're not here because I'm
good at basketball you aren't here
because I'm funny in a movie this is
because we we see the world in a similar
place around love and kindness and hard
work and the basis of my community is
sitting on such significantly important
virtues and so it's incredibly
fulfilling because it's very hard to be
popular in a contemporary way you could
do it as a principle as a guidance
counselor as a religious leader as a
parent but it's hard to be pop culture
popular and talk about the [__] I'm
talking about so it's incredibly
fulfilling
so one thing that just like intrigues me
a lot about you is how old you are but
how much love and compassion you have
when you're
you know can't forget yourself and what
do you do to do on a daily basis I think
it was a gradual process like I was
definitely the kid in like third grade
that if like somebody picked on someone
it didn't feel good like I felt bad I
just always had a lot of compassion and
empathy and so I kept building and
building and building and then it just
became my perspective on life which was
like none of this [__] matters it's like
you aren't liked by people if you aren't
giving love to people if you're not
trying to leave a positive impact so
it's the [__] that I talk to myself
about every day it's the constant
conversation they're having with
yourself that happens because I'm
thinking every day how do I bring value
when I make videos when we make content
I'm not thinking how many likes am I
gonna get I'm looking at that for
performance but I'm looking at it for
why would this be good for everyone here
to see like like what am I bringing them
when people take photos of themselves
with like a watch I'm like what is that
doing for people my argument is that 90
are feeling worse about themselves so I
try to focus on that and so I think it's
the conversation I have with myself it's
like
who you're being every day the whole
reason I'm here it's just you and to
thank you
I feel like you support me in believing
me more than like the people I've
surrounded myself with and it's like
[__] that I love that Mercedes that you
know what that's such an interesting
thing that hit me when you just said
that that's exactly how I feel I
genuinely do believe in people more than
the people around them not always but
often because I really believe in the
human being and I feel that like your
videos are always like what I need to
hear and I love the honor and
appreciation you have for your mother my
mom's my best friend and she's the one
that's like I'm where I'm at because of
her and when I see you talk about your
mom it's like people think I'm weird I
love my mom so much and I'm like Eric
Gets that so thank
Fitness that the world needs and for
pouring into people like me and everyone
else I appreciate that thank you very
much I know you're always talking about
like
Armenia with nothing
nothing started a business and they're
doing pretty well I sometimes feel bad
because I'm kind of content being
we work full-time but I'm just like
a high-end career look I think not
everybody has to strive to build a huge
business you can't put pressure on
yourself for something that you're not
you don't need to be an entrepreneurs
everyone's like you have to be an
entrepreneur and nine to five is like I
think that's crazy I think nowadays
people need to fight to be happy like
I'm happy being an entrepreneur and
working hard but if you listen carefully
to my videos I'm not saying do that
that's why I love following you because
you're all about like it's not all about
money
is the most [__] important shop on
Earth I'm the byproduct of a mother of
three garyvee is not me garyvee is the
byproduct of a mother of three you don't
have
to just fight to be happy period
[Music]